okay we're recording and we're almost at
the batteries so we don't know how long
this video is going to last
um Cheers Cheers good morning John good
morning Hank it's is this your video or
mine because it's my camera it's my
video but you're gonna edit it
and then upload it on Friday no no
I don't love this it's gonna be the
first ever we're drinking tinglings
which is Ting and rum yeah
Ting is like grapefruit soda from
Jamaica yeah which is where we are we're
in Jamaica on vacation and we were
thinking what's the most radical
counter-cultural thing that two content
creators could do
in 2023 and that was to go on vacation
and not make content about it yeah we
haven't made a single Tick Tock I took
four pictures and they're all of cats
one two three four there they are which
is hey who's editing this
whoa whoa I thought we were taking it
down in October 2023 now you're gonna
make me put pictures of cats in the
video yeah I'll DM them to you all right
I'll put a picture of like what the
Ocean looks like which I think is even
bigger news than cats they're really
good cats yeah Hank and Catherine will
look away from a beautiful sunset across
the Jamaican Horizon to be like look at
the kitty
no apologies it's great um we've had an
awesome time this is but yeah we have
not collabed at all we've not made any
content instead we've been making a
different kind of content called life
yeah well I'm trying also just trying to
it's perspective making and also
perspectively I just really like John
and Sarah yeah and so does Catherine
it's been a good hang system had a lot
of fun hanging out yeah that's one of
the things that surprises me sometimes
is that we don't fake it for the camera
uh we genuinely get along it's so fun
we've had like two fights since we
became professional partners
you a lot of them have been forgotten
over the years I think I guess we had a
fight like two weeks ago but it was just
you were being so annoying I wasn't even
like mad at you about anything you
hadn't slept in like 48 hours is that
I'm gonna put that on a little bit on
you or the situation I felt like you
were being a little Annoying earlier but
I was really tired John bet Sarah a
million dollars that this couch swung
like uh like a little like a fun outdoor
swing I I it doesn't I asked her if she
wanted to bet a million dollars and she
said no because I was so confident you
seemed very confident and that's part of
my trick it does not swing as it turns
out it's a stationary outside bed but
it's still pretty nice yeah this we have
now been going for two minutes and 52
seconds yeah this battery light is
blinking red I mean it's this is
exciting for the viewer and for us
except they actually know when the video
is gonna end yeah you should probably
just say Hank I'll see you on Friday
just in case Hank I'll see you on Friday
okay we'll keep going though okay until
oh all right well that I thought this
was going to be a no-cut video and
you've now been making me do the end in
the middle in the Middle East and if it
doesn't make it you just cut there and
that's the end okay yeah all right all
right I feel like I'm gonna have to put
at least three Cuts in this thing I'm
definitely four cats and some ocean
definitely cats are important the
project for awesome starts on Friday
we're extremely excited about that part
of the reason we've been on vacation is
to Center ourselves get ready calm come
to the project for awesome from a place
of lots of energy because it both takes
energy and gives it uh so it's gonna be
intense 48-hour live stream Extravaganza
starts noon on Friday you missed it what
did I miss it's four minutes and one
second now
oh we're already gonna have to do cuts
okay
I thought you were really gonna try to
do a no-cut spectacular
well you once I've got to put in a
picture of a cat Hank I might as well
just spend four hours editing a YouTube
video you know what cancel the big